I'm Mike Sadowski, with Chet's Cleaning,
and we are out of Madison
Heights, Michigan,
and we clean just about everything
except for walls and windows.
Today we're going to be
cleaning a dirty boat cover.
The simple reason for the boat cover
is just to keep the inside of the boat
not looking like the cover did.
So that way, the cover takes
the brunt of the elements
rather than the boat.
The material of the boat
cover is a Sunbrella material.
It's a solution-dyed acrylic,
so it has great stain-resist properties
and it's pretty friendly for the sun,
which is how it can survive out there.
This one was primarily
animal issues flying overhead
and some mold that was built up from use.
I would guess it was
probably about five years
out in the elements.
The chemicals that we
use, it's called DOT.
There's dichlor granules in
there, which is a chlorine,
and then there is a surfactant,
so a detergent in there, which allows us
to get the soil off along
with the mold and mildew.
DOT is very chemical-friendly, in terms of
it's not going to burn my skin at all.
It's virtually odorless.
We use dwell time to allow the solution
to break down any of the soils, mold,
mildew that's in there.
Needs at least a half an hour,
but I can let it sit overnight at times.
Once that's had time to
do what it needs to do,
we go ahead and use agitation.
So a scrub brush, either
by hand or mechanical.
The yellow machine, it's called a Cimex.
It's an orbital scrubber,
so the scrub pads at the bottom
are just going in a circular motion
while the head turns in
a different direction.
What it's doing is pulling
apart the fibers slightly,
the way they're woven, and it allows
the soil and embedded mold and mildew
to release a little bit easier
rather than still being
tightly woven with the fibers.
The high-pressure water is
what really breaks apart
everything that's down in there.
It's a mild detergent
that we use in rug washing
that is going through
the power-washing gun.
So, it's not just water,
it's soap and water
coming out at the same time.
I'm using the broom to push
water off of the boat cover.
A lot of times, whether
it's the boat cover or rugs,
it's very hard to see
staining that's remaining
when the water's puddled on there,
so I'm just pushing it off,
so that way I'm able
to see what's going on
and make sure that I didn't miss any areas
while I was power washing.
The bath that it goes into,
I was just using it to help rinse out
all of the detergent and the products
that I had put onto the boat cover,
because whatever I use I
want to make sure I get off.
I put it through our rinse wringer.
So that was just squeegeeing
out some of the water
and hitting it with another
high-pressure system
to get another power-washing
job going through,
and making sure I was getting
it as clean as possible.
From there, we went ahead
and hung it and dried it.
With boat covers, I
typically don't get them
when they look clean,
where rugs and upholstery,
I would tell you it should
be cleaned regularly
no matter what the appearance.
Boat covers I go a little bit different.
They are cleaned as needed.
If it gets real bad and you want it clean,
that would be the time.
If it's a generic cover,
it might not even be worth cleaning.
You just let it live
its life and replace it.
Other times they might
outweigh the benefit
of trying to find material
and get a new one made,
and just have it cleaned up,
buy them a few more years.
The biggest thing that I've ran into,
whether it's from sun damage
or aggressive cleaning,
you actually cause that Sunbrella
to not become as repellent.
And Sunbrella does sell
a product to reapply
that repellency, or the protectant, to it.
So, depending on the scenario,
people want to look to get that done also
to make sure it stays in good shape.